a manhunt is under way for a suspect who
killed a recent high school graduate in
a suspected road rage attack 18 year old
Bianca Roberson was shot in the head
just before her car veered off a road in
the Philadelphia suburb Emory green is
following the hunt for the killer recent
high school graduate an honor roll
student
18 year old Bianca Nicole Roberson was
on her way home when police say she
encountered another driver on the road
another car a red pickup truck merged in
at the same time and a man in the red
pickup truck pulled out a gun and shot
her in the head killing her this is now
a murder case police in Pennsylvania say
they are looking for a white male
driving a red pickup truck seen here in
this blurry traffic camera image for
that man who fired the shot turn
yourself in now
Roberson graduated from high school just
two weeks ago and had plans to attend
college in the fall he was a good girl
on a roll student
investigators say Robertson's car hit a
tree shortly after leaving the road and
that the incident was a random senseless
act of violence if he's doing this in a
moving vehicle for just to be first in
line at emerge I mean I just can't
fathom what would bring someone to that
well officials say counselors will be
available this morning at the high
school where she just graduated offering
to help students deal with this sudden
loss David okay Anne Murray thanks so
much